so it's it's my prayer my pleasure to
introduce the next speaker
um so Dr uh Bartlett Mel is an associate
professor of biomedical engineering at
the University of Southern California
Dr Mel's research focuses on using
computer models to study brain function
at a single cell and system levels as
well as the role of active dendritic
processing in the sensory and memory
related function of pyramidal neurons Dr
Mel received a bachelor in science in
electrical engineering and computer
science from University of California
Berkeley and his PhD in computer science
from University of Illinois
Urbana-Champaign so please welcome Dr
Mel to give his talk titled dendrites
lie at the Crux of a customizable
cortical Computing architecture
foreign
thank you very much and thanks to um Ila
and whoever else was responsible for
inviting me I really appreciate it I'm
really looking forward to this
um so this is a picture that takes me
back a long way
um not maybe that far but when I was in
graduate school I was very inspired by
this it's a it was centoga Tai's kind of
conception of what the cortical what a
module of the cortex was was like uh
mainly from an anatomical point of view
you know you have pyramidal neurons and
you have lots of different interneuron
types but it was organized in some kind
of a structure he felt and many people
have been interested in over the years
and what that structure is but just
identifying that there is some kind of
repeating module in the cortex it's a
fascinating idea because what's amazing
about the cortex is that this this piece
of tissue I mean which is basically
similar across the cortex is able to do
state-of-the-art visual processing
state-of-the-art Sound Processing
state-of-the-art tactile processing
language processing motor control
language did I say that already
apparently not doing memory very well
and emoji emotions and and so on and
each of those things the cortex can do
better than what we know how to do any
of them from a technological point of
view how do you make a piece of
biological tissue that that can do that
um one way to ask that question is what
are the parameters of the circuit that
you can tailor to make it do so many
different things so how do you how do
you get at this so we we have thought
that a good place to start is the
pyramidal neuron which is the the main
cell type in the cortex or the most
numerous cell type and the and the the
ways that
we like to operate or to kind of bounce
back and forth between two different
kinds of questions one are you look at
the hardware such as that neuron and you
ask what are the hardware components
able to compute these are things you
could do with biophysical studies and
sort of ask what the Computing
capabilities are and people have been
doing this since uh my you know since
the 1980s and uh I was going to say my
postdoc advisor Christoph clock was one
of the earliest people doing this and
Tommy pojo and so on and so you can do
this and get some ideas about
capabilities and then you you need to do
this too which is to study the problem
that the neuron is presumably involved
in solving and and the back and forth
between them gives you some good
leverage so I'm going to first start
with that and I'm going to start with
the summary slide
uh this is our current working model of
one parameter one here's a pyramidal
neuron cell body basal dendrites apical
oblique dendrites tough dendrites and
these are covered with spines and
synapses excitatory synapses mainly but
inhibitory synapses also mainly
clustered around the cell body but
occurring in the dendrites too it
received maybe ten thousand or Twenty
Thousand inputs a cell like this they're
coming in over space in the dendritry
and time and we need to know what's the
input output rule for this very
complicated cell and so over many years
and I should say many people's work
we've kind of this is what we think and
again it's lots of other people's ideas
are built into this but that you have
individual dendritic branches uh you
know sort of mainly representing things
that are near the sum of these thin
dendrites they individually are
separately thresholded non-linear units
whose results combine or can add to the
cell body and then then the apical tuft
is a separate Network that that has
separately thresholded units again and
then the total there is helping to set
the gain for the cell as a whole so this
is probably not a perfect model but it's
uh it's it's it has some merits and I
think I have
um oh yeah and then I wanted to add
another thing that I just learned
recently from uh from people in Mark
harnett's group and Mark also uh and uh
you know uh uh Dimitra and
um and um uh Courtney and so on that
there are other dendrites there's also
variation in the degree of non-linearity
in the dendrites on on an individual
cell from sort of very non-linear near
the basal dendrites because of a lot of
nmda channels and less non-linear in
other words more linear as moving up
into the apical trunk so you have this
interesting variability of the
transduction capabilities of individual
dendrites and so that's going to figure
also into our thinking so you have a
pretty complicated model cell I actually
want to measure I want to mention
something about this little picture here
so we think when I said separately
threshold unit I didn't necessarily mean
that a dendrite adds everything up and
then applies a sigmoidal threshold or
something we found and this was in
collaboration with Jackie Schiller's
group there were experiments and there
were models that it's best to think
about an individual dendrite at least on
a cortical neuron as having a kind of a
multi-dimensional sigmoidal input output
function which depends on the relative
locations of inputs so you can have
inputs on the distal side and the
proximal side and they interact in an
asymmetric way and they create this
multi-dimensional surface there and I'm
going to allude to that later how that
could be quite functionally important
anyway that's that and I just want to
put for as a contrast the conventional
neuron is the point neuron we have all
the excitator and inhibitory things
being added up at the cell body with
weights and then that number is fed to
the axon so this would be the the neuron
inside a conventional neural network
now let's go back to
um let's let's go to this and look at
look at start looking at problems that
these neurons are presumably involved in
solving so I'm very interested in object
recognition and if I said to you what is
what is this right here what would you
say
okay and and how about this one
yeah okay great yeah should I should
have picked an easier one okay big okay
anyway nobody you guys did well
um so how do you know what something is
um well you know as artists know and
psychophysicists know for example Nancy
kenwisher uh in here uh the key
information needed for recognition is
contained in line drawings for humans
and you can Flash these at yourself uh
20 to Second and you can process them
very easily um so that's it and these
line drawings are basically containing
Contour information
um Contour information or the boundaries
of the objects boundary between the
horse and the background the boundary
from the source's leg and the rest of
the horse and so on and so boundaries
are critical for recognition
so how do you
um
how do you do this okay I'm going to
well okay
okay when do you see a fire hydrant
good okay you guys are really good
that's Irv biederman's thing I really I
really like that it's fun so how do you
do boundary detecting how do you make a
boundary detecting to run to the cortex
so if you want to answer this question
okay first thing you notice is
orientation tune simple cells now this
is this picture is not Hublot weasel's
picture but they already figured out in
1962 that you had cells that had that
like were sensitive to light along a
boundary and sensitive to dark on the
other side of the boundary and they were
orientation tuned and that they were
they since these days uh cells simple
cells like this are thought to be the
first stage of object boundary
protection in the brain because you know
because they're oriented and they like
boundaries okay and they're also assumed
to be good at it which is false so we're
going to
um now situate our kind of Neuron model
in the middle of this cortex which layer
two three and here's layer one it's kind
of you know anyway it's an abstraction
and imagine that we're going to make
this
um we're gonna we're gonna impart to
ourselves a simple cell receptive field
by having a driver neuron that has a
receptive field and it looks for light
dark contrast and it's going to send
some excitation onto the dendrites of
this cell and therefore give it an
orientation tuned response and also I'm
going to throw in a divisive
normalization circuit this cell
activates some inhibitory Neuron a
parvolvium neuron like a basket cell
which sort of sends feed forward
inhibition this is basically David
heger's model from 1990 that you have
sort of feed forward kind of linear
filter with giving the orientation
tuning and then a feed forward divisive
normalization so if we do that we're
going to have a cell that responds you
know to some extent to horizontally
oriented boundaries
okay now here's where
uh oh and you know that's what I'm
representing here with that thing here's
where I said that that kind of a a model
doesn't detect boundaries well in
natural images these are not natural
images but I'm illustrating a point so
if you have a linear filter that likes
light up here and dark down there and
you pass that through a device of
normalization then it's going to like
this that's a good boundary but it's
weak it's going to like this just as
much and it's going to like this just as
much and the problem is that this thing
is much more common in natural images
this kind of a structure than this so if
you tune the threshold to accept this
pattern as an input to detect this
boundary then you're going to get a lot
of false positives which is to say low
precision and that you can confirm
easily in natural images so there's that
that's just the correspondence there now
could you do better than that by having
having a whole bunch of you know let's
say hundreds of cells with different
orientations and positions sort of in
the vicinity of this reference location
where you're interested in a boundary
and take all of their responses and do
something better with it that would be
better for boundary detection so what we
decided to do was study boundary
detection this is completely independent
of the brain these are the two people
Gabriel and Roman Chandra who
worked on this and there's a pre-print
on biorarchive
so here's what we did we gathered ground
truth data on and off object boundaries
so someone shows you this and says is
there a boundary cutting through this
reference thing you say yes and if it
says here you say no and so we could
take thousands of images and sort them
into the yeses and no's and then for
each of them we can collect all these
hundreds of filters that are around
filter one filter two filter three Etc
and collect their responses on the yes
and no categories and we did this for
about thirty thousand natural image
patches and then we applied Bayes rule
to get some kind of expectation for what
one of these precursor cells in the
neighborhood should tell to your the
boundary cell into to help it detect
boundaries better and there's an
assumption here which I'm not going to
talk about today it's not actually a
true assumption but it nonetheless lets
us apply Bayes Rule and see something
that will happen okay so here is what we
learned from this simple exercise we
said the probability yes there's a
boundary given that you could measure
all of these cells around you has this
kind of mathematical form which has one
term per neuron so here's the cell with
this receptive field relative to the
reference location a different one
relative of the different one and there
would be hundreds of these and what what
we found was that each cell there were
different kinds of things you could have
a cell like this which is really well
aligned with the reference location can
send to the boundary cell and should
send as its activity increases along
this axis moving to the right and
increasingly excitatory uh input so this
would be like an excitatory connection
from this cell to this cell here since
it's kind of an incompatible receptor
field we have predicted from this simple
analysis that you should have sort of
increasingly negative effect on the
boundary cell when this cell's response
increases but then there were other
cells interestingly that had kind of
partially overlapping and partially
aligned that had this interesting
pattern we predicted that would be
non-monotonic where at first it would
sort of excite the boundary cell but
then as its response get higher it would
then sort of become inhibitory and we
realize that all of these this pattern
of activation or or of interaction
functions between this cell and the cell
or this cell in the cell could be
subsumed by one sort of simple model
where each of these cells both directly
excites
and then also indirectly inhibits the
boundary cell and the the sort of uh the
compounding of the excitation and the
inhibition would allow you to get all of
these different effects okay so we
trained
um
we trained a network to learn what
actually natural images would tell this
circuit to do here's a whole bunch of
cells for each of these precursor
receptive Fields we'd have several
variants with different thresholds and
then each of them so we have hundreds of
these cells each of them has one weight
directly onto the boundary cell that's
the excitatory connection you know
between these nearby cells and then an
excitatory weight onto these inhibitory
neurons which kind of collects all of
this and then sends one inhibitory
number to that cell this was the network
that we modeled we trained weights using
a Delta rule a single layer learning
rule not back prop and then found these
interaction functions and we found that
we do indeed have pure excitatory
effects between cells that are well
aligned and we have pure inhibitory
effects between cells that are poorly
aligned with the reference location and
then we also found these these
non-monotonic interactions which are
quite interesting and and but but as I
said the whole thing is very uh it
relies on the circuit Motif where you
have direct excitation and indirect
inhibition which is a very common
cortical circuit Motif and just quickly
we found that this also helped boundary
detection so if you wanted to this is a
Precision recall curve it says how well
you're going to detect boundaries with
those different models if you're just a
single simple cell you're really bad you
want to be in this corner here where you
have 100 recall meaning you detect every
Edge there is and 100 Precision meaning
when you say yeah I see an edge it
really is one
and you want to be there but this is
where the simple cell is if you wanted
to catch 90 of edges you'd have 20
Precision you'd be constantly saying
yeah I see an edge and 80 of the time
you're wrong but this circuit with these
learned boundary cells gives you about a
50 increase in the Precision here and it
gives you an even larger if you wanted
to be just to have a really high
threshold and only accept the best 50 of
edges and throw the rest away then
you're going to get more than a doubling
in the Precision from this simple
circuit so here's how we think about
this visually here's that sort of
starting point and here's our offset
cell that has a different receptive
field that sends its a certain amount of
learned excitation or a certain learned
amount of excitation under the dendrite
of the cell and then simultaneously
sends a certain amount of learned
excitation onto the inhibitory this is a
somatostatin neuron which is in the
circuit also and that basically captures
the interaction function between this
cell and this cell that helps our Target
cell do better at boundary detection
here's another one here's another one I
could do this all day there would be
hundreds of them but anyway this circuit
that you're looking at which and we know
every single kind of connection is here
um is is helpful for boundary detection
so we only know that because we actually
studied boundary detection and said what
do you need to do and by the way it's
kind of this puzzle you know there have
been different groups that have looked
at spines neighboring spines and
cortical neurons and in V1 and found
that often times on a cell that has a
certain orientation tuning you find
inputs that have different orientations
kind of scattered all over the dendrites
and people have remarked about this
Arthur Connor had like that was like one
of the main take-ups of their paper 10
years ago or so and David Fitzpatrick
they found that you have quite a scatter
of orientation and that's what you would
expect in a circuit like this that is
trying to use all these neighbors to
help do better boundary detection so
conclusions from this is that okay what
do we what do we hear so basically you
can do much better about boundary
detection which is so important to the
new one if you just use that kind of
these local interactions and all of of
them can be positive none of them can be
cat well okay I don't want to say that
I'm going to say the whole set of
interactions can be captured as a family
of rising falling and then these
non-monotonic u-shaped functions and all
of those can be represented by the
simple incitation circuit we call it
sort of you get it right inhibition and
excitation glued together a common
cortical circuit Motif which we know is
there okay and all you need is you need
kind of a diversity of firing thresholds
in the simple cell population and a
single layer learning rule to to set up
this circuit okay so that's kind of
piece number one now here's a different
problem
long-range boundary completion
so you're a rhinoceros well
you have you're looking at a rhinoceros
you have
Contour elements they tend to align
right because Contours tend to be
continuous so if you had something there
and you saw something there then you
might infer this something in the middle
that's kind of a non-linear completion
process when can you infer completion
and extension and so on so what's the
interaction there that you want to have
or what so it turns out neurophysiologic
neurophysiologically this was back 1995
it's ancient history from Charlie
Gilbert's group neurons in V1 and
monkeys seem to respond to the
conjunction of aligned Contour elements
so here's the cell whose receptive field
here likes horizontal things you put a
horizontal bar there you're going to get
20 30 spikes per second you put a
horizontal bar outside the receptive
field nothing inside you get nothing and
then if you can join the two together
you get sort of a doubling of the
response here by this thing that was
itself a silent activator and that kind
of quote unquote multiplicative
interaction has been reported and these
are the the post-dividualist time
histograms but and people say oh yeah
yeah it has to do with Contour detection
but I mean what exactly should you do
with a number that's you know a a
contrast level here and an oriented
contrast level here what should you do
with those two numbers how should you
combine them I mean we see something
kind of vaguely multiplicative but what
do we really want there so again we
turned and then how do you get the
multiplicative interaction so here we
alluded to these biophysical mechanism
that we have studied previously so here
you have the cell that would be driven
by this input would be delivering
excitation not just anywhere but biased
distally on the dendrites and the input
that would be driving this neighbor over
here
this is just another parameter I'm
calling it a modulator because it's
sending a horizontal connection over
here that's going to modulate this
cell's activity
um contextually modulate the cell's
activity would be biased proximally this
is our hypothesis why because we have
evidence from our earlier studies with
Jackie Schiller that this Arrangement
gives you this asymmetric multiplicative
interaction that seems reminiscent we
thought to the kind of classical
contextual interaction that we're seeing
in these neurophysiological experiments
but again we need to study the problem
to get a sense of what the um
what the uh what function should the
neuron compute well we can turn to
Natural images again this was the work
of late Jin when he was a PhD student so
I'm going to show you two columns here
one is where we collected data from
natural images and here what we did was
we basically grabbed patches of natural
images and we measured the oriented
contrast here with a little linear
filter and then another one here with
another filter actually wasn't linear
but it was a simple filter and we take
those two numbers and we would collect
them and then depending on the value of
these two numbers we would bend the
patch so these are the ones where both
of the numbers are low the center our
Center and our flank are both low
there's no oriented contrast there and
then this is the ones where they were
both high and we found it I mean
obviously you when you have both of them
hide you're going to tend to have
Contours running through there and so we
could go through this packet or this
pile of images and rate Contour
probability we had a scoring system and
you're going to find a lot of high
probability here and a very low
probability there and other
probabilities in other places so we did
that
and then we also did to compare we did
something where we took a range of
numbers and we activated proximal
synapses and distal synapses in all
combinations to see if that proximal
distal interaction could capture
something about the probability based on
a center and a flanker input and so we
collected we ran biophysical models we
collected Action potentials and we
counted them and we made surfaces for
both of these exercises
and here they are and probably not
surprised that they're very similar
because otherwise I wouldn't have set up
this slide in this way anyway this is
like based on having humans say I saw a
contour I didn't see a contour you can
see basically at that Center contrast
goes up even without any flanker
contrast you know the probability people
start labeling and saying yeah yeah I
see a contour goes up slightly or
modestly over here the flanker by itself
doesn't do much of anything but in the
presence of a strong flanker you can see
this curve is much steeper than this
curve and that's that multiplicative
interaction so it came out of this this
sort of I want to call it psychophysics
but anyway human labeling and and that's
the this black frame here is the exact
same black frame here this is what you
get when you put distal input and
proximal input the proximal input by
itself doesn't do much but it greatly
increases the gain so the distal input
when it's present and so what
quick clarification the essential number
in the area is the
um nmda channels in this cable
yes
looking out well it's hard to say in
words in concisely the reason why but
it's it's we have a paper on this that
sort of goes through and makes a really
simple model that explains why proximal
and distal are different from each other
in this case but but the point is that
if you looked at these two ways of
generating the data you can't come up
with more different ways I mean this is
you're having humans look at pictures
and say yeah I see something I don't see
them here you have a biophysical model
with nmda channels and cables and all
this kind of stuff and they produce the
same Services tells you that
this type of model a dendrite is
natively capable
of computing this weird function that
you need to compute and we show that you
need to compute it because we collected
it from natural images in this way
so we draw this picture by taking those
away to make up some space and then here
let me put this guy over here and what
what I did was I added a guy who's a
little bit farther away has a receptive
field that's kind of outside
the reference location aligns with it
however and his connection comes over
here and makes a connection onto the
proximal dendrite which is what we're
predicting you know can be wrong can be
right there's some shreds of evidence
that it may be true and then is also
piling more inhibition or actually I
should say more excitation onto this
inhibitory somatostatin neuron to which
basically gives you another parameter to
change or you know to tailor the kind of
modulation and we talk about how
flexible this circuit is for generating
modulatory interactions through these
horizontal connections so that's that
function piled on top of the previous
function and we conclude that this
long-range contextual thing can be can
benefit from non-linear spatial
integration mechanisms in dendrites the
previous thing did not depend on that
okay problem three this is very quick
because it had nothing to do with us
this is noticing this fascinating thing
that it there's cells in V1 I this kind
of you know you think it sells V1 being
sort of cells that look for orientation
tune things like simple Gabor functions
so this is from um shiming Tang's group
in 2018 they found that cells a large
proportion of cells in V1 with calcium
Imaging and monkeys liked and insisted
on very you know on more complex
patterns that had at least two
orientations involved and so they used
all these different kinds of patterns
and here for example you have one that
likes that kind of insists on having
this curve and if you don't and if you
do kind of anything different other than
a very similar curve then you you get
much lower responses you can see here's
a piece of the curve here they kind of
you know I don't know you could look at
all these different variations and the
cell's very picky also is picky about
location but it requires multiple
orientations that are kind of in a
conjunction here this cell requires
literally requires a curve uh well
requires a curve and it also likes it's
pretty be specific to the location so we
have higher order features being
computed already in V1 in the monkey two
now our in our picture the way that we
add this is just to sort of State a
biophysical fact that if we had a couple
of cells over here that each encoded
some oriented feature and they were both
you know in this this created some kind
of a shape like a a pointy Corner that
if both of these cells are reacted
together and their synapses were kind of
co-localized or intermingled on the
dendrites this is exactly the kind of
configuration where you get very good
non-linear interactions and you get nmda
channels activated and you can make a
little conjunction detector and an and
gate sort of because you have nmda
channels if you can co-localize synapses
it is now established that that synapses
that fire together can can wire together
at the might you know at the very fine
scale in the dendrites and also I want
to point out that even back in the 1980s
Gordon Shepard and others were saying
that you could get and like interactions
they didn't know about nmda channels but
they knew about sodium channels and they
were already talking about this kind of
thing so we're just basically throwing
it onto our picture to say that that
other function of E1 conjunction is
easily computable within the dendrites
of the cells that are there and that's
just what I said and I don't want to
repeat it so I want to add this this one
more problem which is very interesting
which is uh how do you do Q combination
okay so uh here let me just draw this
there are cells in V1 that combine cues
like luminance and color these are
called color luminance cells Elizabeth
Johnson is one of the people who's done
a lot of work on this and and so somehow
these these inputs think of them as like
little driver simple cells or something
or piling their their outputs onto this
one cell that has to then be sensitive
to both color and luminance with the
same orientation but but again how
should these two inputs be combined
should you put these on one dendrite and
these on another should you add them so
you multiply them should you square root
them and multiply it by seven I mean
what do you do
so we again we turn to our our go-to
approach which is we uh how to combine
boundary because we decided to study the
boundary problem with with image label
and this was this was the work with
Francis Mel defonte
okay how should a neuron combine them so
what we did
here's a here's an intensity Channel
seeing the world and you can see that it
sees it's good down here you get these
good sharp intensity edges here but you
don't get so much intensity edge here
but here you get a lot of good red green
here but not so much it's like very
complementary where the red green
channel is seeing the horse and where
the intensity channel is seeing the
horse so we said but if you've got these
two measurements what should you do with
them again should you add them should
you add them apply a threshold should
you multiply them if you had cells that
were responsive individually to these
things so we we labeled a whole bunch of
image patches and we with human and we
assigned values to the Contours and we
use that to train so what is the
function we trained a conventional
network with three layers with back
propagation to see what the combination
function looked like and here's what it
looked like it's a some interesting
non-linear function is a red green
intensity goes up you get more value and
the 10c goes up you get more value you
have this interesting non-linear
interaction there from the data
and we you know if you apply that then
you get a nice complementary kind of
image where you get sort of it's strong
anywhere that this one was strong or
this one was strong and and and it did
it did what it did it did what it did
with what the natural images told it to
do
but we weren't really that interested in
back propagation and an arbitrary
Network so what we said was that there's
a trick that if you want to learn
non-linear functions but you don't have
back propagation you only can sort of
train one layer of Weights there's a
trick that's been known since first I
remember this is from Mar and albus's
models of the cerebellum from like 1970
where they proposed that the granule
cell layer was basically created a whole
bunch of non-linear basis functions
actually you talked about this too uh
yeah happy
um in in your talk about having a bunch
of non-linear basis functions makes it
really easy to learn the things you need
to learn so we think well look there's
got to be some basis functions the
dendrites might be able to provide a set
of non-linear basis functions sort of
spanning some space that makes it really
easy to learn a function so we we
developed that and we we trained this
one layer of weights and found that we
can exactly I mean pretty much exactly
imitate what a multi-layered network
could learn
um with with a single layer of Weights
now here's where the basis functions
come I think this is the coolest thing
that I'm going to tell you today so
where do you get nonlinear basis
functions coming from a bunch of
dendrites so there's this very little
known feature here's a pyramidal neuron
this is from uh de Felipe at all and an
anatomical paper there are double
bouquet cells in monkeys and humans in
V1 not in rodents so this is a very
highly evolved feature have these very
narrow inhibitory axonal bundles you can
see this one here coming down here it's
like 10 microns in diameter and you can
see this kind of streaky pattern is
those bundles just coursing down through
the visual cortex and this is a top view
you can see they're on like a 30 Micron
pitch here on the you know kind of
irregular but spaced out like that now
why would you have that thing I mean
I've never heard of anybody even notice
knowing it was there I mean I don't know
how many people read this paper this is
a fantastic paper but why would you have
it so um here's how we think about it
the dendrites of these cells are sort of
sticking out into this lattice and
they're going to be hit within a bit you
know when the dendrite kind of happens
to go through a bunch of these you're
going to get a lot of inhibition in
several different locations this one
here goes out it misses the inhibition
and then sort of catches a little bit on
the tip this one here might catch a
little bit in the middle of the dendrite
and then doesn't catch any on the way
out further so basically it creates this
inhibition pattern which is kind of
randomly peppering the dendrites now we
happen to know from previous biophysical
work and this was also these were
experimental studies that depending on
if you've got a bunch of excitation on a
dendrite depending on where you would
Place inhibition
um you get a it modifies both the gain
and the threshold of that dendrites
input output function and creates like a
little different non-linear basis
function of you know whatever is coming
into that dendrite and so what we you
know you have proximal inputs tend to
knock down the gain just like proximal
like citation tends to boost the gain I
showed you that earlier and distal
inhibition tends to to increase the
threshold without changing the gain so
you have this kind of combination of
gain and threshold changes and we think
that that these I'm drawing here these
kind of double bouquet axonal bundles
kind of hitting the dendrites all at
random different locations is
essentially creating a whole bunch of
diverse non-linear subunits that putting
synaptic plasticity on top of allows
that one layer of weights to represent
non-linear functions okay so we think
that's uh that's maybe what's going on
we I mean I don't know you might have
another idea what these double bouquet
cells are for okay I think I'm pretty
much done I threw I clicked the button
and I threw some other things up in here
just to kind of confuse you we haven't
done any work up there I I just writing
down what other people have kind of told
us that we have excitation here we have
its own little sort of incitation
network
and and I kind of wanted to uh overwhelm
you with with the picture
um now it's it's a slightly multi-headed
Beast because we have slapped everything
that we know kind of onto one neuron
whereas this these multiple functions
might be cascaded even within V1 we know
that all of these things happen in V1
somewhere somehow but it's it's uh you
know anyway it's it's it's it's uh it's
it's valuable to compare to the
interaction between cells in a
conventional neural network where you
have a precursor cell sends a connection
throw weight to another cell all you can
have is a weighted connection and then
this cell all it can do is add up a
bunch of weighted inputs so it's a
linear combination rule this is
incredibly simple compared to the cell
cell interactions immediate cell cell
interactions direct monosynaptic
interactions which are much more
intricate and flexible and we think that
picking apart those kind of biases in
the cortical circuits and then doing
this kind of uh normative analysis with
by picking problems and studying them is
a very good way to help decipher this
whole thing and so that's my last slide
and I put the title up here because the
title actually appla kind of applies
pretty well to this picture
um and I I want to leave this kind of
imprint this on your mind and try to
think about this type of a network and
in comparison to the interconnection
schemes in conventional artificial
networks that people use every day for
uh for doing brain light computation
and that's all thank you
[Applause]
so now we have about five minutes for
some questions uh maybe I would like to
start
um so on the second part of your talk uh
you showed that you could train uh one
neuron uh to F type of uh response
profile that resembles uh human
behavior in identifying you know those
those Contours
um
is there any reason to expect to have
single learning V1 that would precisely
align uh with
um you know Contour integration at that
level uh is there is it being described
or or would we expect this something to
be you know something Downstream if you
want well the the reason that you would
expect it is based on this normative
assumption that we know the importance
of Contour detection and Contour
representation for object recognition
um we know that the psychophysicists
have told us that okay so that has to be
computed along the visual pathway so we
just kind of assumed let's say a neuron
has to do that and it has these cues
available we can then now those are
clearly stated assumptions we can then
go to Natural images figure out okay if
our assumptions were true then this is
the function that that neuron would need
to compute on those inputs and that's
all we did and then we said oh the
function that it computes we think that
the cortex would allow it to compute it
because it has this Hardware component
and this interaction and this dendrite
and this channel blah blah blah so we
kind of tried to connect what we the the
our normative assumption and our
analysis of natural let me just holds
the cell should try to compute based on
its inputs and then we kind of explore
different Hardware solutions for doing
it and then that's kind of what this
picture contains is like a compendium of
every Hardware solution that we that we
came up with
um I understand that the normative uh uh
inspiration behind it my question is
more like is there any reason to expect
that a single neuron would match well
because the same type of uh you know
match could be at the population of
neurons is there or maybe not the reason
but is there any advantage for this
being well yes because if you're trying
to build shape representation knowing
that there's a boundary to certain
location in a certain orientation is
valuable period
um if you tried to construct an object
recognition system you would want to
know that again I'm making a normative
assumption so I'll keep doing that all
day long
um but I don't I don't know how to
answer your question better than saying
that and I but I can also say that
neurophysiologists have not tested cells
in V1 for boundary detection
capabilities they'll put a grading there
and say oh it likes this grading but
that's very different from detecting
oriented Contours and natural images so
that has not been tested so we've
actually got in in our preprint an
experiment that would distinguish
between a cell that just an orientation
tuned cell and likes gratings from one
that really likes boundaries and doesn't
like non-boundaries and and so but those
experiments haven't been done yet
thank you
Ela
or Robert
thank you
thank you that was very nice and so
so uh several at least several years ago
in computer vision
people think that the convolutional
neural networks are not very uh good at
seeing shapes that they see texture
better and that's how they do a lot of
the object classification and you have
shown us that it's definitely
non-trivial to do the Contour detection
right so do you think that
um that's part of the reason that these
convolutional Network because they're
missing some Foundation like fundamental
com computational properties of the
dendrites here that they tend to focus
more on the texture rather than the
Contour yes I would just answer your
question more generally the answer is
yes I believe what you just said but I
would say just generally conventional
networks have no biases in them
essentially they're just stacks of
identical units okay you throw in a
normalization you throw in a pooling
layer but basically these are generic
units in generic kind of Stacks with
weights in between them they have they
lack any of the representational biases
that you're going to find I mean look at
I mean we know this stuff is there I
mean we know these neurons have this
stuff there it's just a this isn't what
evolution gives you it's a huge mess
it's hard to figure out it's complicated
you don't know exactly how it works but
it's incredibly biased towards these
computations how did we do incredibly
good visual processing and visual cortex
an incredibly good Sound Processing in
the other areas of Cortex you'd have a
picture like this only it would be a
little different you know and so yeah
the conventional networks just have not
they've gone with you know using back
prop and Grading descent over 50 layers
just try to solve the you know to try to
do Evolution it's not a good way to do
Evolution you're not going to design a
cat by doing back prop you know or
versus a dolphin you know I'm revealing
my biases here uh you know you need to
actually study the thing and optimize it
for that thing I mean that's what
evolution seems to do so I'm kind of
into that
[Music]
only Improvement between when you take
non-linearities
so what do you think is limited in the
performance
sort of limitations that you see that
will get us to the point where we can
really recognize Andreas
are you asking sort of What stages would
follow these simple computations here in
order to do
like recognition of objects well I mean
that's that's a big question we have to
sit down and talk about that one uh we
you think about that a lot and we're
working very hard on that but I can't
that's not something that's open to or
amenable to a concise answer
you're saying basically how to solve the
rest of the brain yeah or the rest of
the visual system and that's you know
uh artificial neural networks um I'm
trying to understand the bias that
you're describing over here right so
there's a bias which is I mean we can
think about each cell as doing a
multiple non-year computations which you
could imagine Outsourcing to a network
level complication one difference here
that I guess is a form of inductive bias
is that each of these nonlinear units is
not receiving an independent error
signal right like when you're using the
Delta rule you're giving one single
error signal to the whole unit to the
whole neuron yes but each neuron
consists of these multiple
nonlinearities so that's that's
fundamentally what's different here
right because when you do back
propagation and conventional artificial
Network then each unit gets an errors
well they're multiple no I would not say
I'd say that's a piece of this but I'm
saying there are multiple things that
are kind of I would call biases I mean
in a general way first of all the
components certain components do things
that are very difficult
are very difficult to do compactly in a
Convent you know with conventional units
for example this proximal distal bias
which has kind of a multi-dimensional
sigmoidal input output Behavior if
that's what you need you need it's much
more compact to just use the dendrite to
do it than to construct or hope that
that the gradient descent will find just
the right circuit for you you know from
50 layers up you know um so that's
that's one thing the connectional biases
in the cortex are very strong you don't
sort of have really simple connectivity
diagrams like these long-range
connections are known to travel over
millimeters and they'll Target the guys
of the same orientation so there's this
very powerful anatomical biases and you
have you know so that you can kind of go
down the list of different things where
the architecture is
clearly designed to do something
specific and but there's a there's a
there's a kind of a
this feeling in the field of the deep
sort of the deep networks field and this
was propounded by Google and other
people don't study the problem
don't figure it out that's too hard it
takes too many Engineers just put the
network in there and hit it with
gazillion training examples and light
gradient does not do the work for you
and I I just think I mean you know
obviously deep networks have done
incredible things but they have not done
an incredibly good job of building you
know like circuits that actually do
Vision as well as we do they build
brittle systems they fail in just
catastrophic ways in weird ways and so
we need to put a little more energy into
figuring out what the problems are and
what the optimizations are thank you
I think that concludes the Q a so let's
think
[Applause]